it's lucky you're beautiful because
there's nothing up here what that's mean
did you just call me dumb
you went straight to dumb like woman i
was like oh you're wearing my grandma's
sweater and then you're like you're dumb
james
[Applause]
there you go
[Applause]
oh wait really bad
come on plumb one on there
how did you feel about not being in
these civil wars they sort of benched
you for that one how did you feel about
that and that's what everyone thinks i
actually chose not to be in it
i was like busy
do your kids get excited about the fact
that daddy is thor
one of them i've watched okay so one out
of three is good for me yeah that's
enough
one thing that's really cool
and and i come home from work and he
says papa did you you fight the monsters
at work
i said yeah i've been doing press all
day plenty of monsters
a dinosaur from
don't mistake me for a shark
i'm uh
i'm a dolphin oh
so people come up to you and they want
you to tell a specific joke
well they're just coming tell me thor
jokes
like um yeah go
uh
you know the joke about um thor spends a
night with this woman and the next
morning he says i have to tell you who i
am you know i'm thor she says you're
thor i can hardly walk
when you went to the beach the other
week and you had that beach umbrella
did you know that it would eventually
turn into the pants you'd be wearing
today
first of all do you use this yourself uh
every day you do
uh morning noon night yeah do you think
that you can do any activity with it on
does it limit you in any way no no not
at all you could train with it and you
could surf with it uh-huh um you know
you could get intimate with it
tell me about spider-man why wasn't thor
in that one oh because you know it was
really for like the front-running
avengers in this movie you know it's all
about kind of yeah who's going to step
up and take rdj's spot which is why i
asked where was where was thor
when you say you get intimate with it so
your partner it does not your partner's
going to be fine with it it's probably
their idea okay
so say my wife has three of them
that's great that's great yeah so not to
get too personal but you and your wife
use this while you're being intimate
yeah yeah yeah
my uh my older brother actually chewed
on a scorpion one time he was
chewing on something and my mom said
well what have you gotten a big old
scorpion in his mouth and
he survived so i think it was uh how did
it get in in his mouth he's picked it up
it's hungry i think
you picture him like they're like you
can have a sword you can have like
giving him 15 amazing things and he's
like hammer i love the the really large
hammer head and the short stumpy
shaft thing and then you're
put that away
um you're never coming back uh who is
the most likely to make you laugh in the
middle of the scene
hemsworth who'd you pick mark ruffler
and why does he make you laugh because
he uh he gets all his lines
women always flock over the hair is that
weak still kicking around and can i have
it
i bring it out at certain times you know
when the romance and with my wife is
dipping i'm like well honey you remember
the wig
i don't care do the dishes
change the nappies hey guys
no
i can't
oh uh uh what's his face chris pratt
yeah
what's the worst crazy i know because
that's a character name hey guys crew
friend here uh i could have said that
who has the avengers tattoo
you guys have it right does chris have
it i have a scratch and sniff of paul
rudd's face
and like thor was depressed but we was
it depressing walk for you walking
around like that that was so much fun it
was good
did people treat you differently
yeah every time i stepped toward the
catering truck they were like no no no
no
nothing guy you know the treadmill uh
but
you and your brothers how did you three
interact
we're good we're you know just three
boys dead in in the bush we uh
we leave to jason to a couple of uh
we lived to jason to a couple of farms
and there was a uh
there was
um
when did you move to the united states
six years ago
named something you do in a movie
theater besides watching the movie nice
uh
mike out
[Applause]
cocktails one two three martini
it's my first time oh yeah yeah it's
your first time happening to everybody
[Laughter]
three two one
[Laughter]
what's up buddy
let's come on let's go let's have a look
how's things man he loves it high five
loves it when i do that i don't you do
you do what scene did you find most
challenging to film for this movie and
why was it because of the people in it
was it because of the director was it
you know just anything like that it's
all very difficult because of the
directors and the people in it this
whole film
it's an awful experience so
myself jeff and tom are going back to
our own movies from now on this is where
the ladies get changed in here
and uh i think the vanessa's vanessa
you're in here yeah i'm changing oh good
well i got you that uh that water here
after oh thanks you can just leave it oh
my god
i hate you yeah you'd hit it wouldn't
you yeah i know yeah it's good ready one
two three
ah what a shame you know jimmy i want to
say one thing
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you said which ocean was it a part of
right and i said i didn't know because
it was the best right in western port
bay which is actually
near the tasman
ocean tasman sea but it's not part of
any ocean specifically
so i've done my research that's what
wikipedia says anyway
in case you were going to ask me
i was somewhat prepped
it has to be part of some ocean yeah but
it's not one of the main oceans and
according to wikipedia the first line is
phillip island is actually not part of
any ocean
this was just in case i knew gonna
wikipedia is largely fiction well
my biography's true said i had seven
brothers four sisters yeah i was on a
various amount of tv shows in australia
now wait a minute you had seven brothers
no that's what wikipedia says oh well
see there there you go did we went on
the guardians of the galaxy ride at the
one that drops like crazy we went on it
i don't know where were you
where did you go i didn't i didn't well
i went i was there on february 7th for
my kid's birthday we went on that ride
and i almost yacked oh is that right yes
i was gonna do it it was really it was
good a couple of yeah
that worked for you yeah my team came on
it but i took my daughter on it a couple
years ago when it was previously called
the tower of terror or something
and uh she wasn't tall enough and and
she was really upset and i was like nah
forget this come here so i grabbed a
couple of snickers bars and things and
slammed in the back of her shoe under
her heel
so i propped her up because she was like
this my shot walked up i was like uh
what about now
so and they're like okay and you come
i'm like
sir
snickers brush
you're responsible as well
cheering it gets worse
so we're sitting in the chair and this
thing it's you know i don't know how
many hundreds of feet
we're at the top and i'm looking down
she's strapped in you know the seat is
massive on her and i'm like you know we
beat the system honey why not
and then it drops and she's like
just grab on and she's like screaming
the whole way down like you know
i was like maybe there's a reason that
there's a
height maybe
[Applause]
so
don't do that don't do that